[Applause]
rockets will push here comes Westbrook
blow three right to the rim again yep
that's what we envisioned the Russell
Westbrook coast-to-coast drive and
finish Westbrook ins control to the
basket to
Westbrook has a lot of space to get his
speed going towards the basket there's
the contact and walk and he closed it
right to Gordon that was good defense
[Music]
hammer right there that gets the retina
pop their feet
[Applause]
turning on the Jets of the three-point
line
[Applause]
Charcot west war he went by buddy he
like you were standing at mud and then
ricocheted out the big court
[Applause]
both guys pick your pick your wizard on
the bow but Westbrook with a great
finish inside
open-hand plants as plugins about Volvo
open to the three-point line but instead
of settling for the three he is
attacking the rim he's been doing that
over the last several weeks way up over
the top of yogic Paris had it partially
blocked
rustle on the road
[Applause]
by Harden so Westbrook who emphatically
slams announced Orlando players with
ease
[Applause]
simply let's see it part it right into
your living room Westbrook with the
flush house is able to keep the ball
alive Westbrook to the basket once
trailing by 20 you have to be
competitive to be successful at this
level but Russ's ma be the post
climb the ladder watched it look at how
high westbrook gives up off the floor
and the hang time it takes to wait for
the pass wow that was a great pass what
up and two Boy Adam left coach you like
that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report